it's it's tough enough ooh what's going
on with this one
whoo wait a second wait a second
should I do this one I'm gonna do it and
that way if I respond to that one I'm
gonna dive into another one here two
minitor I'm entering right now
okay so 29 minutes and 19 seconds left
Kaali round one okay I'm just getting
off of taking beatings here so it's
gonna be nice that actually to have um I
almost mouse slipped it's not nice to
have mouse lips
I mean I meant to say it's nice to be
able to play fast and maybe hope that I
could be winning on time because winning
objectively it seems like it's not gonna
happen
nope I just feel like maybe throwing my
H pon down maybe I could be winning
games like that let's get my rook on an
open file Queen e2 if they don't Castle
they're doing well to Castle I'm doing
h3 to stop Knight h5 because I want to
play Bishop to f4 I want to pinpoint
this pond so I'm thinking Bishop f4
Knight d2 to c4 typical idea I also want
to stop this pawn from moving or at
least get my rope a file to work with
okay let's get my Bishop out and I'm
just dropping a pond okay maybe not
let's take care I thought this pond
could have been taken and maybe I want
to do what next huh let's see let's see
let's see let's see let's go here I did
want to do Knight d2 to c4 but that's
gonna be hard to do and I guess this
Bishop is gonna come back is there
something with my knight coming here in
my queen getting on h5 looking for made
on h7 a minute 18 and 18 on this planet
even realized Queen d2 threatens this
but maybe not rook takes c4 and I'm dead
so or no no no that's actually still on
because I could take the rook and be on
the Queen so this is on and they're
defending and this is a little bit more
loose than now and maybe Knight d2 is
now available maybe let's try it 92 to
c4
this night is pretty good I'd rather
actually just come here and out a lot I
want to get my night here actually if I
get my night here can I manage that if
the bishop moves I take the rook and
then take on a six a minute eight to
less than a minute for my opponent ah
let's see what else
fifty seconds for my opponent the points
are doubled just making sure
42 seconds Oh Queen exchange interesting
Wow um
let's see what they do to that are they
gonna take my queen no they're good they
should take my bishop or no no I'm on
the night if Knight takes I take with my
queen these are just working out tell
you what
I didn't even calculate that why didn't
I see that the Queen takes bishop was on
okay I got to do that see two could be
taken maybe maybe I might want to take
the bishop and then take here or take
your next Queen take c2 is probably
pretty good
the queen is actually running out of
squares though g4 and I'm threatening to
trap the Queen I think but they only
have they have less than 10 seconds so
let's see what they do they got to run
away with their queen I'm just gonna
throw in some fast moves double rooks
I'm on this pawn and now d6 let's come
back here I think I'm just trying to
burn time in spring with that and this
okay back to tournament okay oh I can't
win objectively I have to I have to rely
on my best friend right now and my best
friend is time so now we have this going
on these like I guess like an exchange
Cara no this is an exchange care I don't
know what you call this okay let's get
this and and Bishop to d6 and Queen to
c7 looking for the white king's throat
basically at this point so 97 queenside
castle rook g8 and hopefully bad things
happen H file opening
are they gonna let me have this h-file I
would love that
in my kingdom might actually be quite
safe let's do this first see what that
Bishop wants to do I think I'd like to
get my king here just take my bishop
please just take that let's take this
though the bishop pair and I'm gonna
Castle kingside I don't want to get into
a race and I could defend with Bishop
back and let's get this in there's no
hurry with doing that let's do this and
hit that rook stood Brent some time
maybe okay you make a bite at this now
take with my rook and then plate up I
want to watch this pawn watch over that
h6 Square as well and let's open up some
stuff oh is this getting scary or what
c5 am I missing anything I better not be
I have enough defense let's chop that
and then put that pawn maybe in a pin
and b2 is under fire as well
rook here this has to be good as well
okay this is a nice pocket here for my
king let's rook up no no no no no no
let's trade trade I've got a minute
I could take here let's not do that
though it's off for a queen exchange
first and I want to keep everything
defended here let's run with this
looking for Queen here next yes now this
is definitely gonna have strayed xym on
the rook I'm on the pond Queen so in a
rook and pawn endgame I'm still doing
well here I just want to be cautious of
f7 definitely want to be cautious of f7
but now it's a Queen trade or mate
you're gonna fall into me what's what's
the story now I have to trade Queens at
this point so not much was accomplished
there with that Queen move
okay let's get my rook here I want to
play to b5 where it acts as both a
defender and attacker if look before I
take and play a three and then I
pinpoint the beep on okay so this is
still a difficult win still very
difficult win ooh
seventh ranked they're neglecting their
seventh rank why would they do that
they're going after Mayan but I have to
say for king my king can run away and
they're theirs can't so easily start
check-in and I'm just gonna take wait no
no wait a second I should I should just
trade like this there's no need for that
and get skip behind this pawn these
pawns are fast
let's get over here before there's a
check let's kick that King back
threatened me my time ticking now to
mate coming up mate can't be prevented
back to tournament 1111 6 6 the average
rating is 1700 so it's much lower than
that 5-minute tournament that I entered
so what do we got
are they gonna take on see let's try
this and maybe I could get that
LightSquared Bishop but if they take
away from the center efore it could be
quite strong I want to try and pick up
that Bishop pair and I don't think that
there's a rush with doing that just yet
let's work on my development but let's
change the structure a change of plans
here let's get this in targeting this
point I could get that in and now let's
take that and support this Bishop to a3
and now the position is opening up whoa
interesting ok if they push again I'm
gonna I'm gonna play f3 okay now I'm
gonna challenge it
now I'm gonna challenge I didn't want to
I didn't want to I want to maintain my
d4 pawn because c5 would have been very
weak and I think this is strong there's
got to be some issue against this and
keeping my bishop here is a good idea
rook to e1 and then this e pawn push if
they if they don't move their King
there's gonna be a problem I have this
move available but they have like tricks
against this point I don't like that so
let's get rid of the knight and let's do
what next let's push see what they have
now this could become a big problem now
their King safety timely pawn push okay
now the pawn is pinned because that rook
isn't on the board and my king I think
is safe here and I'm winning upon
because the pressure I placed on that d5
point I might as well pre move this and
then that so I have a majority over here
these guys are pretty quick let's get my
bishop involved first and do what next
Queen here is that going to be an issue
hopefully not what about just Queen
takes pawn there's got to be something
simpler 42 seconds
it's just be a little bit sneaky here
see what they do with that and okay this
is a little bit scary Oh
check the pin and Queen here if the this
is has to be good alright i I could take
this with check but let's just play here
pin and this is a one King and pawn
endgame this is a one King and pawn
endgame
okay 26 seconds is plenty of time okay
so let's get my King involved now 24
let's make sure I reach oh wait no why
did why did I allow that exchange to
occur that's that's okay this is still
one okay let's pick up this pawn
and let's make sure I don't know sleep
now let's give him a king back over here
less than 20 seconds okay they resigned
back to tournament 16 16 15 14 and then
me 12 18 minutes left in the tournament
here we go this guy has officially
disconnected you can't see it on the
screen but it's showing that they
disconnected okay so in the meantime
hello though those of you that are in
the chat there okay
zombie Nick and shark Lackey Big Jim
vice Kali rum is good Oakley well it's
my bad Ashlin Aldo or just Naldo I
always kill that name Cosmo
hello and okay um let's see so I don't
know what to do okay they just they
disconnected so let's let's see another
game that's going on against somebody
who has the top score and I believe it's
this guy so let's go for the person
who's playing white come on beat this
guy up Wes 26 come on white this is a
good position they're dead equal time
it's still on my screen showing that my
opponent has disconnected that's why I'm
away from it so 1850 this is a nice shot
very good exploiting the pin this guy is
a 2,200 player the the black side versus
in 1850 and now isolated pawn is being
pinpointed a lot almost every piece
except that rook I got about 30 seconds
before my lamb my other game my game
finishes kingi - that's a sad move to
have to make to defend the knight so
where does the knight go or does the
bishop move Oh
or does the knight not move at all it
happens fast time controls and it looks
like black is gonna be winning again so
let me come back to my game now I'm
gonna close out in less than 10 seconds
this game is going to be over with and
hopefully I gained some points here some
good points let's see what happens
okay back to tournament 16 leaders 26 I
think was what was read I need some
quick wins here let's try something like
the Grand Prix attack and I get this in
to preserve that light square bishop and
get castle Queen e1 to h4 probably just
back that out okay clean here pawn push
coming up okay
Bishop h6 typical idea in the Grand Prix
get rid of that Bishop rook here the
pawn falls this is gonna be an issue big
issue coming up here very big issue
actually make the the typical mating
theme right here Knight g5 pawn takes
Bishop takes rook takes Knight Queen
takes age seven mates stuff like that
coming up soon I think this is a problem
I don't know that it was the right idea
to bring the bishop over here maybe
there should have been an earlier Knight
d5 beat 94 move so let's run with what
move at this point I think Knight here
is the correct thing to go with Knight
right here the last time I saw that and
actually turned out to have a good move
but not let's Oh take take take take is
that working out do I get the Queen
actually I get the Queen if the King
takes let me run this let me on this
throw I take here first because I take
there the knight recaptures and now do I
take here oh yeah I could take here and
if pawn takes I get this fork oh no I
have that no I don't have that fork
anyhow if this this pawn is here I was
thinking Bishop takes pawn at this point
then they hear but now Queen takes this
is available now it's working the King
has to take otherwise it's made pot if
the King takes actually it's still gonna
be made rook check and then Queen h7 so
this is working out okay that's me
okay back to tournament 26 okay I think
I gained around 38 30 26 26 how much
time is left I forgot to look at that
one and this is the guy that's in the
lead
Oh important win I got to get this one
so this is my chance to maybe come back
against that leader can I please do that
let's get this in and maybe pinpoint
that epon is this move going to be
played okay let's get over here and
maybe Knight d4 Knight d4 oh wait right
here Knight takes pawn takes Knight
there and I pile up on c2 again it can't
be defended again I'm gonna run with
that I'm on c2 and oh no the night plays
there to defend no Queen here Queen here
I'm on this twice so I think that's
working out let's let's do this I am
looking this or this pawn how do they
defend this all right now they could
just move their Bishop I missed it okay
they've not moving their bishop because
there would have been ripped to c1 gonna
have the Queen trade Knight back here
challenged that night and then get you
crashed through on c2 if that pawn falls
then so too does this pawn I actually
have a time advantage let's get rid of
this and I'm liking my position here or
maybe I'm not
or maybe I am hang on Oh make up my mind
pawn takes let's go up on takes I didn't
like maybe this pawn move so I can still
have pressure against the Queen side but
I'm gonna have to come over to the B
file okay now if the pawn moves I get
this guy but okay let's do this and then
maybe push here okay now let's do this
and now there's gonna be triple pawns or
I have a ton of targets along the C file
okay let's come with this rook I didn't
want to have to deal with that rook move
I want to be able to take here it's take
do oh I missed that oh why did I let
that move in oh that's a killer what do
I do a minute seven mmm that's a killing
move right there
okay hopefully I can get this pawn
somehow oh that's not happening
that's not happening why would I ever
allow that to happen
ah that should never be allowed to
happen ever and now that pong is just
gonna move or that's that's actually a
bad note if they do that right away
let's come back here I want to get my
King to see - this is scary I got a
blockade can I get this pawn please just
let me get this pawn okay I'm getting
this pawn who's winning in this King and
pawn endgame though I gotta go for it oh
wait I have a good position back to a
good position pawns on dark squares oh
man okay I got to work on time though I
gotta go quicker
I'm not going quick enough still not
going quick enough this pawn up and then
this I should have taken that pawn maybe
outside pass pawn oh I'm able to create
an outside pass pawn I think I have um a
good position here go ahead is this a
one game oh wait a second um I don't
it's not oh it wouldn't be a win there
oh wait you know what I do I take here
this is the correct idea I can't give up
my pawn I can't get that pawn up what
are that where they're gonna go oh okay
this is good this is definitely good
mate in a couple wow what an interesting
endgame that was okay mate back to
tournament an important win right there
I gained ground on that went 42 38 38 37
10 minutes 40 seconds left okay double
those points let's try c4 Knight c3
interesting endgame why did I allow that
pond to get past on c6 that is
ridiculous okay yes back to tournament a
quick resignation there 45-42 another
quick resign no what does that move
doing
actually I just had a flashback of the
the one game where my opponent through
those night pawns out a couple squares I
ended up losing it was it's not a good
flashback either not at all okay so look
to be eight pinpoint Bishop Bishop b2 Oh
dark square weaknesses I want my Knights
on d4 I'm winning material I should have
done that a move sooner I'll take that
rook resign resign okay I got a minute
seventeen they haven't about him any
advantage but that's quite all right
I'll take the rook and the knight is on
his way and that he's definitely on his
way here to this d4 square and the dark
square Bishop has been given up let's
watch over this square and target C the
C pawn as well and that's exactly what
we're seeing right now I probably should
have grabbed that guy too and now I
could get them or offer more exchanges
here clean exchange okay more simplified
more simplified position they're not
resigning a minute 9 to a minute 47
let's kick that night away and then take
the pawn maybe or stop the knight from
coming back into play if they played 99
h3 I play g5 and I could just give that
light square bishop op if I really want
to its control this bishop along this
diagonal this uh these pawns alone would
negate that bishops presence there and I
could just maintain my bishop so what
more is there to say here I guess
pinpoint f2 is the name of the game at
this point
rook b8 rippy to let's now let them have
any fun on open files okay more
exchanges f2 coming under fire right now
kick that night away bishop d for a
minute to a minute sixteen come on let's
go here I got this ah minute six they're
not they're not gonna move there there
you go
well round one wrong pre-move I can also
take there with check but it's can't be
prevented anyhow so the the night is
boxed out with my pond let's keep the
king bottled up the night officially
cannot move
if the pond is challenged i just support
it and okay yeah let's let that let that
king run away over here
so what do they do now there's nothing
good nothing good I could probably no I
can't I can't pre move that and it's
just push and then I could take and then
push again and it can't be stopped they
have a pond they have pond movement it's
a million one two three main to in fact
right here mate next
okay back to tournament 61 oh somebody
has 92 they have ten games in already I
want to get paired up against that guy
maybe I need some quick wins
I might need some quick lends towards
the end maybe I should be focused on
quick wins at this point with 92 yeah I
probably need to be getting quick wins
in right now why didn't I just go with
the e4 take on that square is this gonna
be quick win Queen check uh-oh mate I
got the rook at least bad things are
about to happen let's take this and do
what next open up the position get my
light square Bishop out Bishop to f3 the
bishop the dark square bishop is paying
on Bishop f3 and then d5 maybe rook to
d1 I'm on c6 this is on the cards rook
to d1 I don't know if I want a Castle
queenside because these pawns are close
to my king so let's do this however
let's do this right now and I'm gonna go
on Castle door not now I have a pond at
c6 and then I can take on F and I think
I want to do that
stop castling oh there's ninety three
check mmm I think I should be all right
there what are they gonna play about
equal with time okay let's run here
Knight right here now
next and then sink into some light
squares I think I should be alright h4
whoa let's throw a check-in am I getting
that rug tell the bishop action Esther
just come back and let's get this rook
involved I think in a castle maybe I
shouldn't let the castle
oh I'm not liking this I'm not liking
this at all ah should have been a lot
simpler this a minute why my brain
cramping I got a brain cramp man let's
just go here I don't even know what it's
doing there
just remove the night I want the rooks
off the board in the Queen's maybe
that's a good move okay what's I'm
getting kicked around let's turn our
check in here the rooks is just gonna
block the bishops gonna block I got to
get my H rook doing something it's it's
just just not doing anything there is it
oh oh um it's push here forget my bishop
and maybe the King is gonna be okay
let's get this in I gotta get activity
less than 40 oh this is a past pun
what's what's going on here am I getting
another Queen sac that Bishop am I
getting another Queen just with my queen
and then get another Queen it's that
simple
Queen Queen g6 nothing simple at this
point 35 seconds each so much for a
quick win in this game huh
okay trade rooks and then there we go
now there's this am I gonna be up a full
rook yes and I think I need to be oh
well I have a serious time advantage
here so that's good even if something
goes wrong quick I want to get my night
out these ponds are quick actually I
might need my King there's a fork and
probably the picking up of the fish
somehow but not quite and pretty move
that and then this chased the king away
to take that and then come all the way
back and push this pawn he's the Past
pond now and I could stop this just in
time and then have this one Queen
okay back to tournament oh man 104 92
there's two people thirty this is not
happening
no way you know what I have to resort to
the H pond or a quick resign now this
guy just um disconnected I'm going to
resign this game and try and just get
another one in I need to be playing
games to try to win they disconnected so
I took a rating hit their - I guess putt
resigning but I want to be able to get
some wins in I'm gonna try to win this
tournament this guy's not gonna move
come on move
that's all this tournaments gonna end
non movers come on how fun is this just
watching a clock tick man okay there we
go
there we go we got action when age pawns
attack Knight f5 to g3 you know you want
to take the knight as soon as it goes to
g3 or even like this double the pawns
alright let's try it
it's not it's not a good idea to do that
but now let's let's actually take with
my pawn my queen is not gonna be
accomplishing anything are they actually
there just give me the rook why are they
giving me the rook you just that's a
free night that was a bluff
that was definitely a bluff right there
maybe they saw a ghost
they're still not taking my night it's
getting a run back home bring my knight
back home I'm gonna have him sit right
there okay am I gonna hate my Queen
night before or are they just doing that
knowing that like the tournament's gonna
end how much time a minute five okay
there's a minute left on their clock I
gotta move I gotta move
all right I gotta finish the game within
five seconds let's go back it's not
happening
b6 Bishop d7 f7 is under fire oh this is
just not gonna finish it's not happening
47 seconds can I get this one in at
least queenside castle look here
you just have to primo stuff okay I'm
gonna give up the exchange pre move that
even if there's like a night move or
whatever Knight takes I'll just take
there no matter who takes it I gotta go
quickly can I get this win in cream of
that in this night move
uh is there gonna be me I sneak this
move in I need to just move I hopefully
I haven't exhausted oh there's there's a
blunder tournaments over fourth place
fourth place let me close out of that
ah man 124 how do you get 124 what am I
reading this right how does this guy
have 42 games played oh he must have
just kept resigning way just 42 games
right that's what 42 means the guy who
won it was 22 I think was this the guy
that I ended up beating it just wasn't
enough though 124 111 83 and then 78 not
even close the game's all ah another
tough tournament